hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
a video and it's super bowl weekend
thumbs up
uh either way let's go ahead and get
right started with this one so there's
been a lot of talk especially recently
uh in the android community and the
smartphone community in general about
the frequency of which android phones
are released especially here in the
united states people are actually
complaining that there are too many
android phones being released you know
just thrown out there from all sorts of
carriers and manufacturers all over the
place there are just too many it's even
been said that and i quote there is no
right time to buy an android phone so of
course i dived into this then i dug
really deep into this issue and i found
that people mostly have pretty good
reasons say you bought the motorola
droid razer on launch day on day one
well couple months later ces in january
in vegas and the droid razer max comes
out with a much much larger battery as
an upgrade to the droid razer
maybe you were like me and you bought
the transformer prime tf201 when it came
out well again at ces in january the
transformer prime tf 700t came out with
an updated design high resolution front
facing camera and a 1080p display atm t
and samsung just went completely insane
and had a samsung galaxy s2 a samsung
galaxy s2 skyrocket and a samsung galaxy
s2 skyrocket hd all within a couple of
months wow so yeah there are a lot of
android phones out there and that's
gotten people describing maybe three
month old amazing android phones using
almost vague or meaningless words like
outdated or just as old phones so what
does this actually mean so here's the
thing your phone doesn't just stop
working when a new phone comes out it's
your phone's not going to just explode
or turn into a brick or just leave you
because a newer version of it has been
released your current phone loses no
functionality it's still the awesome
phone it was when you bought it and
nothing's changed nothing's actually
becoming obsolete here and if you look
up the definition of the word obsolete
you'll probably agree with me nothing is
actually becoming obsolete even when
newer devices and technologies are
released everything that was good about
the phone that made you buy it is still
good about that phone now i think this
becomes a little bit clearer to
understand when you shift and look at it
like cars let's say you bought a brand
new ferrari f430 the day it came out
like a boss a couple months later
ferrari puts out the ferrari f430
skidaria and you see a scuderia driving
down the street as you're in your
ferrari and you're like wow
this makes this feel so outdated it just
feels so old now but you're still
driving a brand new ferrari same thing
with dare i say it the ladies say this
is my girlfriend she's really hot just
imagine and she's really good at
everything and she's awesome
wow now i think you can see what i mean
the real issue with phones being
released so quickly is development and
support and a word that's
tossed around a lot fragmentation the
development issue is the fact that yeah
these phones are really really different
and while they do defer on the outside
they also differ on the inside and that
means that apps that are available on
certain phones are not available on
certain others which means that there
are going to be app developers out there
not to call anyone lazy but yeah they're
going to say
screw that screw developing six
different versions of my app just to
work on the phones out there i'll just
develop one version of my app for the
iphone for support this has been said
before it's often said that
when you buy a first generation device
you're really beta testing your device
will inevitably get a few updates maybe
even get an os upgrade and maybe get
some behind the scenes changes like a
firmware update but in the end it'll
settle down to being the cool stable
awesome device that you just bought and
fragmentation is a word that people like
to throw around a lot to describe
android but it really ties back to the
development issue where there are yes
different devices with say different
screen resolutions different os versions
different skins on top of them and
that's really what differentiates them
all but the bottom line is
phone manufacturers are not going to
stop making so many phones sure some
random marketing rep from htc may say oh
yeah yeah we're gonna slow down phones
this year for 2012 less releases
really truth is these companies live by
the quarterly report and they are never
going to slow down so much that they
make less money than they do now because
in the end yeah finance is the main goal
of these manufacturers they're going to
take the open source os that is android
and they're going to manufacture their
hardware that is their smartphones and
they're going to shove it in cram it in
and throw it out the window and keep
producing those over and over and over
and over and over again the more
different options they can offer they
figure the more money in their pocket
and that's not going to change anytime
soon if manufacturers did suddenly
magically slow down these devices by a
lot maybe one device per year think
about it first of all that'd be a lot
less money for them second of all you'd
stop getting those incremental upgrades
so remember how the droid razer max was
a much larger battery for the droid
razer you wouldn't see those if they
only release one device per year they
put out the droid razer and for some
reason it pisses people off that
motorola listened to you guys and you
wanted a longer battery life and a phone
and they said all right
we'll have this droid razor come out and
there you go but that would sort of
cease if you only had one device per
year and second companies would be less
likely to take risks if they're putting
all their eggs into one basket once a
year so you're less likely to see phones
like the razer that are so crazy in
their design and so revolutionary you
wouldn't even get a razor max or a razor
at all so yeah it seems kind of silly
but the adjustment isn't going to go
unhappen on the manufacturer's side it's
going to have to come from us on the
consumer side but it seems kind of silly
to complain though doesn't it like
unless you have some sort of inferiority
complex or if you you absolutely must
have the best phone out to feel good
about yourself as a person or if your
phone is some sign of some sort of
status symbol
yeah that might get some hate but is
that why people get mad at new releases
like screw evolution right if if i buy a
phone then manufacturers should just
stop making new phones until my contract
is up and i can afford a new one no
no
sorry no so here's my advice because i
get a lot of people asking me what
android phone should i get
pick the set of features that you
actually want in a phone so if you
describe your dream phone you want a
phone with a big screen look at the big
screen phones if you want a phone
running android look at the big screened
android phones say you want a phone with
a big battery life look at that too if
you want to play a certain game use a
certain app have certain features put
that together match it up and look at
the phones that will match your criteria
watch some reviews play with it in a
store borrow it from your friend that
might already have it you know and once
you've narrowed it down pick your
favorite and that should probably be the
best device for you so if i had to say
what device is for you if i don't know
anything about you that is a process i
would suggest you get the device that
fits you best and you'll be happy with
it because you made that correct choice
i personally really like all the choices
that i get with the multitude of android
devices available for me to pick from
but i know a lot of you guys feel
differently you don't really like that
so in the end what do you think
is there never a right time to buy an
android device
or is there never a wrong time to buy an
android device
this has been mkbhd thanks for watching
peace
you